everyone we begin though this morning
with the contentious issue of whether to
reopen the nation after so much of it
has been closed down due to the
coronavirus some states are starting to
relax stay at home orders this morning
as others brace for the virus to hit its
peak there are nearly 31,000 new cases
of the virus in the u.s. that is pushing
the total number of cases above 700 and
6,000 the death toll is topped 37,000
President Trump says sufficient testing
capacity has been built to allow states
to reopen but some public health experts
dispute that and say the country is
still not ready to track and control the
spread of kovat 19 Michael George begins
our coverage in hard-hit New York City
Michael good morning good morning Jeff
the lights may be on in New York but
businesses are still shut down the
state's been on lockdown for more than a
month and the debate over how and when
to reopen the nation comes at a time
when this crisis is far from over from
Florida to Texas a few select parks are
reopening or will be reopened soon but
carefully we still have to be cognizant
of the six-foot distance between people
the ten people gathering and in
Minnesota golf courses will reopen but
right wing protesters there weren't
impressed they want the state's
Democratic governor to lift all
stay-at-home orders
but as deaths and cases continue to rise
governors in many states are standing up
against the pressure to ease their
orders it's not over we have a lot more
to do the last thing we can do is relax
in Virginia Governor Ralph Northam
reported 600 new cases Friday an 8%
single day rise we're still seeing more
cases each day not fewer so we are not
there yet even in San Francisco the
first city to shut down and now with the
fewest cases and deaths of any major
city the mayor Friday ordered masks to
be worn in public for the foreseeable
future any type of mask face covering a
scarf or something that will cover your
nose and your mouth this will be a
requirement her month-long order to stay
home still stands but there's some hope
needed increased testing is on the way
testing is a part an important part of a
multi-faceted way that we are going to
control and ultimately end this outbreak
some communities will institute
widespread testing to include those who
don't show symptoms and in Colorado
nursing homes are being targeted for
deploying the Colorado National Guard to
conduct testing a three of the largest
nursing homes in the state to help
prevent outbreaks it comes as new
national nursing home data shows more
than 3,600 facilities have coronavirus
cases almost 38,000 residents and staff
have tested positive and more than 6500
staff and residents have died as
scientists and government officials seek
a positive way out a promising report
from the University of Washington an
effective antibody test came out Friday
and officials here in New York say mass
testing is the only way the state will
be able to reopen safely and now
everyone in New York is required to wear
a mask in public Michelle good news out
of Washington glad to hear it Michael